The winner of the $75,000, 2012 Gordon E. Moore Award,...
...in the category of medicine and health sciences.
Congratulations, Jack Thomas Andraka.
"Maybe if we'd caught it earlier."
That's what the doctors said about my uncle's pancreatic cancer.
Like that was even possible with the testing they had.
But what did I know.
I was too young to understand things like cancer or how to test for it,...
...too young to be taken seriously.
One hundred and ninety-nine experts told me I was too young,...
...that they didn't have time for my little science fair project.
But the way I saw it,...
...if the key was early detection, maybe someone just needed to start looking earlier,...
...like during fifth period freshman biology.